this is the problem with all incentive
systems incentive systems are simply
bunk
uh there's another great book called
punished by rewards by alfie cohen
that outlines all the scientific
research on why incentive systems don't
work
and the key reason is that they push out
the intrinsic motivation that someone
might have
to do good work and they replace it with
extra
extrinsic motivation which is simply i'm
going to
sort of just optimize this thing i've
been told to optimize for
in programming and in software
development people have tried for a long
time i mean all the way back in the 80s
we could count lines of code if we kind
of launched
lines of code we'll find the most
productive programmer right maybe
even bill gates who said something about
if you were giving sort of bonuses for
um lines of code it's it's like uh
declaring
the heaviest airplane to be a success
that's just not how
these things are measured the best
program is not the biggest program
the most productive programmer is not
the programmer who writes the most lines
of code
yeah and and when you get to scale and a
bunch of mbas come into the business and
try to quantify it and
now you've got people thinking in this
sort of metacognition
about the business and they try to make
it into a system
right and it's like trying to make you
would never do that with music right or
if you did you create a boy band where
you'd be like okay well we've just
manufactured
you know boys to men or whatever we
think people want but it wouldn't stand
the test of the times
like bob dylan does or you know
whichever artist
actually wrote something soulfully